hi everybody I'm Jonathan Shaun's here  at the st. Louis chess club and today I  got another tactical challenge for you  so when you see the position on your  screen go ahead and pause the video and  we'll see if you can solve this one in  this position it's white to move did you  find it well white has a really nice  move based off the fact that the night  is the only protector of the Queen so  what can eliminate the defender with  check and remove the defender so here if  black just simply takes back white takes  the Queen and now he has a winning  position it actually blex best move  after you captured the night is to play  the move Queen to d7 this is also very  bad for him since we will just take the  Queen and after either recapture White  has a winning position I hope you  enjoyed this video congratulations  everybody that was able to get it right  and if you like this you want to see  more of it subscribe to our YouTube  channel thanks for watching